che cosa cazzo è questo l a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa dj e noi e uno probabilmente
investito cazzo per fermo vabbè
l'abbiamo perso un cappello a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo sul capro
simulator mezza capra simulator quasi io
io non ho parole nel descrivere questa
cosa che cazzo mi significare ragazzi
gli oli mio sogno è sempre stato quello
di comandare una mezza capra cosa cazzo
è successo tu non puoi passare ai
ragazzi sta capra non so come sia
possibile che nonostante abbia solo due
gambe ma più veloce di tutte le altre
messi se guardi non vado più del camion
cioè non so come cazzo sia possibile una
cosa del genere
madonna non c'è allora dimitar nardi
come cazzo aperto prima lurida [ __ ] che
poi ragazzi la cosa non ho capito messa
come fa a leccare le cose come cazzo fai
leccare le plance io sto schifo
paranormal activity 7 capra edition che
cazzo succede perché sto dove la mia
lingua cosa sto leccando di preziosa
ragazze è che io non ho parole
lo chiamerò richard perché è il mio
migliore amico in sto gioco bellissimo
t6 da che andiamo a conquistare il mondo
mai perfetto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io e richard tenteremo un approccio
diretto se ci riusciamo allora tu non
puoi chiamare al telefono mentre ci sono
io che non ho che cazzo scappi
ragazzi io e richard tenteremo scherza
cazzo chi è quel tizio laggiù c'è un
tizio che piange richard facciamo il
culo non è consentito a piangere davanti
a faccia ok solo stanno ballando
dimmi perché dimmi perché cosa dobbiamo
fare di meno turisti meglio di miley
cyrus è anche molto più intonato t come
stanno ballando e direi di andare con
l'attacco tornado ma è così richard ma
richard cazzo ha preso corpo ragazzi
dove allora lo faccio per io lo faccio
fuori o tranquillo tranquillo una fan
culo
ok st mezza capra e lei la cosa più
fantastica che io abbia mai visto che lo
dico perché non ho mai visto una cosa
del cielo non lo non so voi ma mi sono
innamorato è bellissima e la cosa tutti
per ragazzi non è tutto perché perché
quale altra madonna che precisione ad
entrare un po dentro che non so che
cazzo avete mai visto una mezza capra
voi non perché io io ecco cos'ha fatto
ragazzi è rimasto ai rimasti castrato
nel muro non sono stato io e anche senza
che chi paga sta degenerando la
situazione perché si sta masturbando
davanti a tutti fermo rea e io io io
starei mezz'ora guardarlo perché misura
e e godibile sta situazione però non so
come mai sta diventando scena è ok
adesso è nel momento più più hot della
situazione si sta toccando
freneticamente intanto c'è un braccio
che gli spunta dalle pene non so perché
avevo al giorno sarà io sono molto
contento a lei stia lavorando su un
tavolo invece che sulla tastiera ma non
è questo il modo di lavorare amico mio
mi spiace
questo sono io quando prova ad accendere
il computer la mattina ragazzi io ogni
giorno di più mi sento in dovere di
cercare di capire perché sto giocando a
questo gioco mi chiedo mi chiedo il
perché
perché ragazzi è stato ancora che
manifesti tu porca loano che jay android
o sbloccato la capra gigante dove dove
la capri la voglia adesso la capra
gigante dov'è tuo brutto stronzo
affronto mi da uomo anzi la capra meglio
che meglio allora sei stronzo forte
vediamo che cazzo riesce a fare con
mezza che allora [ __ ] salvate
sempre impossibile regalati lancia
addosso una donna pranzo di merda non
mancano altre da io l'ho mancato però
con lui che mi ero di merda ciò a
ragazzi se se made in retromarcia dovrei
riuscirci credo tipo se si va a fan quar
già sto facendo incredibile mezza capra
contro capra in terra questo non so e lo
scontro del secolo bravo a france non
devi neanche la metà di quello che sono
io
avete capito vero la metà di quello che
sono io meta capra quanto cazzo sono
triste
lug i ragazzi ad avere mezza capra che
cazzo è tornata a questa io userò st
capra contro di te fuoriuscita dalla
serie scala tirarla magari castro di
quanta la cosa fa ragazzi si stanno
stuprando a vicenda atti osceni altra
pubblica perché ora ragazzi vediamo
utilizzare come si deve anche noi siamo
robe a caso ragazzi che cazzo esploso
guido stronzo scorsi s'è fatto male a
richard sei tu
ragazzi ho ritrovato richard che arde di
passione per me è sicuro di non voler
mangiare un pezzo di gustosissima capra
non ne va mentre io non ho visto niente
ragazzi voglio vedere il cazzo aver
sbloccato da jan kohout cos'è stanotte
ho letto prima che ho sbloccato sta cosa
anche se sono curioso di vedere dove ok
vi presento la capra gigante che si
muove con una destrezza come vuoi che io
io vogliono norme non mi per essere
anche capire perché la chiamano capra
gigante mi interessa ficato capire come
cazzo ci è arrivata una balena in
giardino e non penso ci avrò mai una
risposta sta cosa qui comunque è
bellissimo anche tentato iran tolar sì
ma non ci viene sì si è mossa ragazzi si
acquista possono lecitamente non so come
ho fatto ad arrivare in mezzo alla
strada
ma ci sono arrivato è bello e bellissima
che tenta di dimenarsi ma non ci riesce
a farmi che arriva il camion
ecco perfetto no in capo un camion
contro una balena voglio ecco infatti ha
vinto il camion non so come sia
possibile come cazzo sono finito su un
albero faccio volare le balene ci
riusciamo
se bellis vi capita tutti i giorni di
vedere una balena che vola per strada io
io a me succede sempre a monza ragazzi
per caso disturbo non perché vorrei
assistere alla
non mi dà fastidio vero se si butta un
po d'acqua in giro 9 grazie è il mio ma
è il mio modo di salutare questo che è
brutto quando la gente non ti apprezza
più per quello che sei
sono soltanto un po sovrappeso cosa che
non va ho raggiunto il mio scopo se
disco magari ad atterrare sui capi
bellissimo sono atterrato sui kart
bellissimo io sto continuando a saltare
non so neanche come su questo sti cosi
che mi fanno perché ci sono balene che
vola cio ragazzi sto gioco lo amo ogni
[ __ ] giorno di più ci siamo ragazzi
il trampolino il trappolino si possono
fare ce la possiamo fare io credit e io
credo in te se una balena vera avrei
avrebbe sfondato il trampolino il
cemento sotto le sarebbe arrivata in
cina forse voglio vedere se entro in
quel cazzo di buco che succede che mi
dovrebbe ingrandire ancora di più giusto
per curiosità
sì sì sì sì
dio mio sono entrato sia possibile ma
sono entrato io santissimo che chiesto
soldi ok ragazzi popolando sono finite
sui cavi dell'elettricità cabria zio con
questo direi che posso aver raggiunto
l'apice del no sense in questo episodio
sicuro vi lascio con la capra gigante
angelo che non so come sia diventata
cugino me lo spiego ma non importa
direi che posso concludere che i ragazzi
come al solito seguito è piaciuto stato
commento mi piace anche a farli facebook
e come ogni video tratterà la
descrizione senza dover estivi
iscrivetevi ci vediamo al prossimo video
e da ragazzi